great now that you have the structure of
the page down you can work on making it
look like the design you were provided
now to do this you need to use CSS or
cascading style sheets now you can
probably assume that style means looks
or the way that the website will appear
to the user but what do cascading and
sheets mean first you can have several
CSS files or sheets that will be
referenced in HTML and all of them will
be used to find out the final and
visible style for your page think of it
in terms of laws you have a national law
that deals with how your country is
organized and then you might have state
laws which tell you what you can or
cannot do in a given state and then you
might have municipality laws which
specify what you can or cannot do in
your city and then at the end you might
have your own House Rules
well CSS is a bit different because with
CSS the most specific rule is applied to
every element so your house rules would
actually be the same as the national
laws wouldn't this be awesome if this
was true in real life for example I went
to school in Orlando and I made it a
rule that we did theme park Mondays
meaning if I had time one one day I went
to the theme park it was a house rule
wouldn't that be great if it was
national well I could go to a theme park
every Monday now this concept of most
specific rule applied is what the word
cascading means you keep going down and
down into the rules until you find the
one that best describes the elements and
then that rule gets applied